hello reject nation it's Greg Alba yeah
and it's John Humphrey over here so
today we're going to cover movie news of
the week podcast for Matt ooh yeah just
so you could hear our voices our lovely
grown-up voices lower register talking
low register for you beautiful bastards
out there ladies listening to the reject
nation today we should have our own
radio stations we were kids and we would
call each other ever hear audio of
yourself when you were really young it's
been a while but yeah it's been a while
yeah yeah it was right here
audio myself and I'm really young I hate
it I hate it I prefer my voice now way
more than when I was a kid I just
sounded like a nasally dog at a terrible
voice when I was younger it was 15 year
old girls thought it was deep when I was
15 well yeah yeah if you got any if your
voice is broken it over you're 15 I
think the smoking has caused it to be a
little more scratched anyway let's get
this show on the road first news story
of the day is as I pull it up here oh
don't you worry reject nation we're
gonna get this on the road first started
a bond 25 is most likely to land at
Annapurna for domestic distribution I
think this is a good idea because bond
can constantly use reinventing an
Annapurna is known to go pretty much
against the grain with the types of
films they produce the only huge film I
know that they acquired rights to from
my memory is Terminator Genisys and that
didn't go down so well there are like
more independent weirder flicks are
pretty awesome but as far as bond 25
goes I think that'd be cool I mean
they're just in charge of domestic
distribution so I don't know how
how much creative freedom they would
have were they considering 70% of bond
you know box office stuff comes in
primarily from overseas but I think this
is a good idea what do you think John
I think it's an all right idea I mean I
used to really love Annapurna they used
to be one of those names that I would
see and be like I gotta check that out
and in recent years they've kind of
fallen off for me like a 24 is really
taken over that so yeah and part of that
has been sort of with their turn to you
know more marketable stuff like
terminator and so I'm a little wary of
this although I think this is a better
fit for them than terminator and I think
this could work yeah I mean after what
they do a Casino Royale really
reinventing the way Bond is done I would
kind of like to see some weird had
appeared that type of Bond film done I
think it could use it I guess that's
what I'm wondering now is if it winds up
over there are they gonna just destroy
they're gonna take it yeah they're just
distributing and I'm like there are
other things it would take more than
Annapurna for me to be like Oh fresh new
gun you know there's a lot of other
stuff that needs to come with that
because you know they didn't deliver a
fresh new Terminator but they still
don't have a director yet they still
don't have a director that's gonna
matter a lot and just the direction the
descript winds up going because it seems
like this franchise needs to figure
itself out again
absolutely well I think they should get
Zack Snyder that's just my personal
opinion yeah I'm with you on that
hundred percent agree that's why John is
my best friend people children so Johnny
wanted to talk about Pokemon yeah I
guess today well dude if we're gonna
watch a whole movie we can't watch
subtitles it's like watching a Greek
movie that's the second movie news of
the way alright on to the next one this
one sounds really cool to me let's see
what John has to say people here we go
joe carnahan is set to direct frank
grillo and mel gibson both names ending
in a g in a groundhog day like premise
but joe carnahan style every day a
retired Special Forces veteran is
trapped in and never
ending loop resulting in his death in
order to stop his endless suffering
Roy must figure out who is responsible
and stop them
Roy played by Frank Grillo this sounds
like a combination a happy deathday and
edge of tomorrow probably gonna be mixed
in with some death you know joe carnahan
hand-held grittiness and stylish editing
which is cool to me and mel gibson
always on board here I feel like now
with all the sexual assault allegations
and and all the talk about people
getting second chances a lot of time to
be Mel Gibson it's a weird time to be
Mel Gibson because he's been having to
come back than all the stuff that's been
happening is there's been more people
talking about how Mel Gibson shouldn't
be having a second chance right now I'm
still okay with Mel specifically him not
everyone else pacifically I'm okay with
and I think him in a joe carnahan movie
just sounds awesome and Frank Grillo Mel
Gibson I feel like could play off each
other really well then I'm gonna help
the same about Mark Wahlberg and Mel
Gibson and that wasn't true but I mean I
I'm a big fan of joe carnahan and i know
that he can do badass stuff like this
and he's also clever so yeah while I'm
not a hundred percent excited about
another Groundhog Day type movie so soon
I think that if anybody can do it with a
lot of style and panache it's it's Joker
man and I like Frank Grillo a lot I'm I
go back and forth a lot on how Gibson
generally speaking but I think just you
know in terms of an action movie yeah
they're great to play off each other
they're great to star against each other
yeah and I I don't know I mean this
premise to me is getting old I have an
idea for how I would handle this premise
I told you that before I'm like how it
handled the sandy repeating over and
over again but that's for a different
video that I might share on a like fan
fiction idea one day but right now I'm
totally on board for this I think joe
carnahan Mel Gibson Frank Grillo sounds
like a match not made in heaven but
somewhere there
okay so this one's a big news story
right here or BS movie marbles living
vampire movie in the works I have not
read any comics featuring Morbius but I
remember him briefly off my childhood my
childhood memories when I watched the
spider-man 90s animated show he's
basically a vampire any kind of colors
and stuff resemble spider-man I don't
remember the details of him there was
there were rumors that that's what Sam
Raimi wanted to do for spider-man for
that would have been so cool so cool he
could have done a killer job on that
yeah and this is gonna be part of Sony's
you know spider-man verse thingy that
they have going on that nobody seems
excited for but the idea of this one
makes more sense to me than a venom
movie I'll give it that that makes way
more sense to me do some weird thing
then MC you probably wouldn't include
but yeah sure Sony movie I don't care
that be that might be cool to check out
what doesn't excite me is the people who
are writing this they wrote Dracula and
told the last witch hunter gods of Egypt
and Power Rangers the only one of those
four that I actually enjoy yeah maybe I
mean it's the most reason once a few
people who like Dracula and all these
big studio movies there's Studios and
producers and directors that have way
more authority and control over what the
script actually is so I can't entirely
know if I should blame it on these two
dudes but then again is Sony yeah I
don't really know this is gonna turn out
I feel like it's probably gonna be crap
that's my initial instinct I'll wait for
a trailer sure but something tells me
this will not be a good film I well it
just it's all in how they approach it
and right now nobody seems to be
approaching any of these universes with
much finesse I think the conjuring has
done it probably the best yes Marvel has
and yeah yeah I mean I like I'm with you
I sort of liked this better than the
idea of a venom movie because venom is a
lot more focal and venom is a lot more
like we got to see them square off
against spider-man with if is this gonna
have spider-man do we know no I don't
think so yeah I could see some of the
some of the lesser-known or the more
obscure villains being more interesting
for solo movies so yeah vaguely excited
to see more be has come to the big
screen yeah I'm not thrilled by the team
but I'm not thrilled but I think Sony
would be a good for someone more
something smaller yeah that that makes
more sense to me but I still think it's
gonna be crap based off who's involved
if it's a smaller project who knows
maybe it might it might turn out well
all right this one this one sounds
pretty cool to me actually hulu who is
really doing their best to to stand out
in TV landmark is like as netflix and
amazon all these other companies have
been doing lately they're producing a
hitman based off the video game TV
series which is the pilots being written
by Derek Kolstad who was one of the
writers in the John wick script yeah and
if there's anyone who's gonna do a
hitman story and write it it's got to be
a guy who was involved in John wick in
my opinion they own the hitman market
right now yeah and the thing with hitman
has if had two movies that both sucked
and with this specific with a video game
for Timothy old I've always thought with
a video game that it would always work
better in a television series format and
the problem is though is sometimes these
video games are so big guys it might be
hard to make it into a TV show hitman is
one of those stories that you can
contain even when you see the chose for
the movies or not like this looks like
crazy 200 million dollar budget movie
yeah and with the amount of
action-oriented series we have now that
are you know shot really nicely I'm sure
there's a way to make this work yeah
especially with after seeing the
Punisher do such a character-driven tale
that features at least one cool action
scene every episode yeah I I feel like
hitman will be much better as a TV show
and you can get everything that the
video game fans would want which is
character exploration and story and then
maybe get one or two cool action scenes
every single episode yeah you can have
the best of your you're crazy plotting
your action and your characters without
having to worry about which one's most
important in two hours Hollywood just
really wants hitman to work really but
then again Punisher third time was a
charm and it worked better when you
brought it to TV so I even though I know
they're not the same property at all
I feel like Punisher had a few failed
movie to attempts and one best when it
wants a TV maybe hitman could have the
same opportunity they're both violent
people and guns involved in everything
so yeah I think this I think this could
work I have faith in it the little video
game movie that could
and hulu which has you know a lot of
shows I don't watch they're doing more
originals they're stepping into the
arena in a big way so I think the one I
feel most passionate about the story
that I feel most passionate about is our
next one which is Martin Scorsese's the
Irish man Irishmen Irish oh you're an
Irish guy an Irish guy so we should have
called yeah Marty some Irish guy Marty
Marty cuz I know Marty personally we
text he said that he I think Hollywood
Reporter reported that he wants to get a
theatrical release even if it's limited
and we have no idea whether or not
Netflix has agreed to that and out of
anything Netflix is producing this is
the only one where I'm like of course
this was going to happen with this film
where Marty's like you know it's just
released on Netflix is there any chance
we can release it and the beaters and
the thing is though is when Netflix does
that they they always do their limited
releases when they put it on the big
screen for only like a couple weeks and
they air it the same day as that when it
comes out on Netflix so you really just
could stay at home and watch it the
thing about the Irishman though is this
is this is a dream team for cinephiles
this is a dream team for people like me
who've always wanted to see an event you
want to see Marty Scorsese even if as
Martin Scorsese and just Al Pacino alone
I was like I've always wanted to see
Pacino and Scorsese film with the
factory game De Niro Pacino and Pesci
all in one movie under the direction of
Scorsese I'm like yeah I want to see
that in the theatres put it in limited
release for two weeks and then drop it
on Netflix because this is this sounds
like got a hundred million dollar plus
project that I would want to see in the
theaters yeah it's gross Izzy's next
movie I mean that I think that transmits
it's Scorsese type of move it's not
silence it's a gangster film you know I
would want to watch silence even less on
Netflix honestly than a gangster no but
like my point is in terms of
distribution and I feel like this could
be partly why yeah yeah yeah I I hope it
makes it to a theatre I mean I know the
New Beverly ran oak Jeff for like longer
than the actual like regular
release was it seemed like so I think
there's potential to see this movie in a
theater but I would be really bummed if
it didn't get some kind of release just
cuz it seems like it ought to yeah you
know I hope it does because I I do not
want to watch this the first time on
Netflix I feel I want to just open their
own theater that would be so cool they
gotta find some way to bridge this gap
because there are if they're gonna be
doing movies like there's some they're
gonna run and they could get more
directors to ya on board for something
like this cuz I'm glad they're willing
to produce two crazier projects yeah the
same time though it's like when you get
like big directors on board that are
gonna want to see their [ __ ] on the big
screen that's what inspired them was the
big screen stuff not television and I'm
glad that okhta made a decent splash in
cinemas because that is a visual movie
and as you know a fantasy about it and
those things I think play even better on
the big screen so I think Netflix would
be wise to to find a more like solid and
and consistent solution to this argument
yeah alright well on this one this is
something that I think could be really
cool it's all rumors at this point yeah
Tarantino's latest film the the story
that he's doing based around Charles
Manson and you know the murderer Sharon
Tate and all that that well it's it's a
it's leaving the weinstein company of
course and Sony and Paramount and Warner
Brothers all emerging as finalists but
the cool exciting part to me about this
story is yes we heard that Margot Robbie
was in talks to play Sharon Tate and
he's been meeting with a lot of other
actors we don't know exactly who he's a
meeting with these big timers for to
find out to to cast in the movie the
rumors have it Brad Pitt DiCaprio but
now added to the shortlist is Tom Cruise
and trust to me I'm like okay Tarantino
has already done a film with Brad Pitt
he's already done a film with DiCaprio
how bomb would it be to do like his next
one to be with Tom Cruise I think that
would be SuperDuper awesome I would love
and I think Tom Cruise would kill it in
a Tarantino film I think he'd be better
than Brett
I don't know about DiCaprio but I feel
like Tom Cruise would absolutely he has
the energy and the intensity and he has
a way with dialogue that would be
perfect for it and I'm sure Tarantino
would know how to write a role for Tom
Cruise better than a lot of other people
might be able to he'd work with his
charm yeah I think that would be a cool
thing to see I wonder how knowing how
Tom Cruise tends to work and knowing a
bit about how Tarantino tends to work I
very much wonder if they could work
together because Tom Cruise has a lot of
control that comes with his you know
signature well for certain films though
Tom Cruise is known to be more of a team
player
like Collateral he was known to be a
really big team player it was let it be
michael mann's project it's like it's
like the bigger films where this is the
Tom Cruise vehicle where he has a lot
more control but for other films where
he knows this is the directors medium he
really surrenders to that and cooperates
that's like the word I hear at least
Tarantino and Cruz in the movie would be
so freakin awesome one if there's any
director now that I think Tom Cruise
would you know settle down and you know
work with ya it's somebody like
Tarantino and it would be cool for crews
to get a movie that could potentially be
a box-office hit that is not an action
movie based as well yes he is better
than any he's one of the best action
movie stars right now but he is more
than that yeah and it would be nice to
see him you know to do a film yeah again
and you know remember why
just his acting chops alone are
wonderful
and then this one right here this is
another big story comic book world at
that I am I'm not excited for I've
actually heard a couple of videos
already on this story and I feel like no
one said the one thought I've had
towards it x-men universe may add James
Franco as multiple man and multiple man
had a brief character in x-men the last
night I remember that
getting him off the truck and he's there
now James Franco in a comic book movie
yes reversing the spider-man trilogy
idiotic but James Franco but he gets a
second chance now James Franco is an
actor where when it's a big studio film
he evidently does not give a [ __ ] he
like he doesn't he's always better in
the smaller films he's always better in
the less big budgeted films whether Horn
films than movies yeah like what if he
does like dear son HBO he's great if he
directs and stars the disaster artist
he's great
yeah even something like Spring Breakers
he's great yeah look at like Rise of the
Planet of the Apes
ah so great in the powerful even the
spider-man trilogy like he's is not as
committed or as invested in those
performances he doesn't he's one of
those artistic actors he's kind of like
a better version of Shia LaBeouf to me
because when he's great he's freaking
phenomenal
nobody's yeah but what he's in a big
film he's like yeah I'm just doing this
for the Paycheck I'm like well like he's
really gonna be passionate about being
in an x-men film like oh I know your
passion for multiple man or it seems
like it just seems like an idea that's
you know kind of interesting but yeah
because I hope he does not agree to do
it you even like showing up in promos
for alien coming I'm like he doesn't
really care about this he's not even in
the film and he shows up like he does
not care he's doing it with a big
project he does for paychecks that's not
where his passion is at yeah and I don't
know I mean the x-men franchise is sort
of up in the air right now anyway so I I
don't know what to think at all in terms
of a new x-men and yeah this is just
sort of news to me I'm sort of alright I
feel like he might be cool as that but
I'm already thinking like am I gonna buy
that yeah I think he's not gonna care
and I guarantee if they cast him he's
probably not gonna care and if I hope
I'm doing this audio in that review I'm
more than
happy to admit what I'm like totally
wrong he's capable but this doesn't make
me exactly excited that's why I used the
word that's why I wouldn't say he sucks
because I'm saying he just doesn't care
when he's in a big film like he knows I
think spider-man was really off-putting
I think there's just too much especially
because he's done yeah he's done TV he's
done movies he's done every kind of
thing and he's done so many jobs I bet
that you know bigger movies especially
like these you know there's so much
changes in committee and stuff that it's
probably hard to really invest on that
level yeah you watch Oz and you're like
I don't think this is a hundred percent
of Sam Raimi movie either so like you
know I got to imagine the x-men will
definitely not just be a director's
media yeah yeah yeah I feel like there's
a yeah there's a specific James Franco
weekend area all right guys that's our
top movie news of the week can't
guarantee you will do this every week I
just found enough news stories this week
to be intriguing enough for I was like
yeah let's do a video let's do a movie
yeah I like covering it no a lot of
people don't really care for these movie
news of the week coverage because it's
not all trending the day of we're late
to relate to all of it but yeah thanks
for listening in tuning in and for you
guys on patreon thanks for watching our
beautiful faces I'd like to say we're
beautiful I self glorify myself we are
beautiful words do bring me down that's
why I read the comments all right well
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
like it follow us on social media and
become a patron eject today will be post
usually daily over there and also make
sure to follow us on the Stardust app
that app allows you do 30-second
reactions for any film TV show and/or
trailer some of these movies we
discussed today will eventually become
star dust rate I think all of them will
be very surprised if we missed one of
these yeah so follow us there right now
we're come I'm John and I are pretty
much covering the Punisher I'm one
Episode ahead of him right
oh boy and yeah it's kind of kind of
tedious shows really slow but yeah is
that detective getting any better kind
of very big kind of all right we'll talk
to you guys later